so the us ease up on these requirements
for brainiacs and other tech oriented
buyers one in four high tech startups in
America were founded by immigrants these
high-skilled immigrants are job makers
not job takers politicians and pundits
are always talking about the importance
of high tech foreigners for the US
economy but the fact of the matter is
that low-skilled immigrants make equally
vital contributions and here are five
reasons why most Americans are not
competitors of low-skilled immigrants
they are actually their customers they
buy all kinds of services from them
house cleaning services child care
services landscaping services home
construction services if Americans can
spend less on these services they have
more money in their pocket to spend
elsewhere which means more jobs created
elsewhere in the economy the Latino
workers and other foreign workers don't
have ties to the local community and
they don't have invested in property
they can pick up their bags and leave at
any point to wherever they are needed
they can you know go to where houses are
being built in Arizona or they can go
and pick fruit in Florida they can go
wherever they want they grease the
wheels of an economy as one economist
put it they add to the resilience and
dynamism of the American economy another
way in which low-skilled immigrants help
the economy is by increasing the supply
of high-skilled workers and these
high-skilled workers are called women
many professional women would be forced
to spend much more time at home taking
care of their children cleaning doing
laundry if it were not for the presence
of foreign nannies or the courier dry
cleaning services or Chinese takeout a
big fear about low-skilled immigrants is
because they are poor they will impose a
big cost of the welfare state but the
truth is that most of them don't even
qualify for most means-tested benefits
that Americans do they don't qualify for
food stamps they don't qualify for all
kinds of federal assistance programs so
in fact they might be saving the welfare
state money rather than costing it
they create more jobs for Americans
because they reduce the cost of a key
input in production which is labor and
when labor costs go down more businesses
can form and when more businesses can
form there are more jobs for everyone
including Americans the fact that there
is somebody else to do menial work like
pulling weeds Americans can do
relatively more value-added work for
instance their English speaking skills
become more marketable in a more diverse
economy with lots of immigrants these
skills would have otherwise been taken
for granted
but they become much more marketable and
command a premium in the labor market